willkommen zu aktuellen Sendung im
Seminar philosophische Theorie der
Aufklärung heute geht es um die nächste
Position heute geht es um Horkheimer
Adornos Schrift Dialektik der Aufklärung
diese Schrift ist 1944 erstmalig in
US-amerikanischen Exil erschienen und
dann in größere Auflage 1947 in Europa
hier auf diesem Foto sieht man
Horkheimer und Adorno und im Hintergrund
den jungen Jürgen Habermas auf dessen
Theorie der Aufklärung wir in der
nächsten Folge näher eingehen werden in
dieser Sitzung stehen folgende
Leitfragen jetzt im Zentrum wie
definieren die Autoren also Horkheimer
und Adorno
Aufklärung den Begriff der Aufklärung
wovon grenzen sich die Autoren in ihrem
Begriff der Aufklärung ab und was
verstehen die Autoren eigentlich unter
einer Dialektik der Aufklärung inwiefern
kritisieren die Autoren auch den Begriff
der Aufklärung und zum Schluss wie
verhält sich der aufklärungsbegriff
dieser Autoren zu den bisher
kennengelernten ich mache oben rechts
ein Link zu der Playlist dieses Seminars
hinein wir haben hier ein paar zentrale
Textauszüge zunächst mal bestimmen die
Autoren Aufklärung als das Ziel von den
Menschen die Furcht zu nehmen und sie
als Herren einzusetzen das führt
natürlich auch schon zur Theorie von
David human der auch gesagt hatte Furcht
ist eine der Ursachen für die
Unmündigkeit die sich dadurch Aberglaube
zeigen ich mache auch da oben rechts
einen Link rein jetzt wird aber hier
Aufklärung problematisiert
die vollends aufgeklärte Erde strahlt im
zeichentrum Fallen Unheils das Problem
der Aufklärung war die Entzauberung der
Welt da steht natürlich auch Max Weber
im Hintergrund der diesen Begriff
geprägt hat sie die Aufklärung wollte
die Mythen auflösen und Einbildung durch
Wissen stürzen also aufklären wird immer
mehr als etwas Problematisches erkannt
wir hatten aber schon bei Hegel auch da
mache ich oben rechts den Link rein
gesehen dass die Aufklärung wenn sie
sich nur negativ gegen Unmündigkeit oder
Aberglaube definiert eigentlich selbst
unaufgeklärt ist Aufklärung bedarf
deswegen begrifflich selbst eine
Aufklärung Aufklärung muss reflexiv sein
das hatten wir schon bei Regel in der
vorherigen Sendung gesehen
das Wissen das macht ist schreiben jetzt
die Autoren kennt keine Schranken weder
in der Versklavung der Kreatur noch in
der Willfährigkeit gegen die Jahren der
Welt wissen das macht es das verweist
auf Francis Bacon einen
frühaufklärerischen
angelsächsischen Philosophen der dieses
Zitat geprägt hat wissen ist Macht
dahinter steht die Idee durch unsere
Vernunft die Natur nicht nur zu erklären
sondern eben auch beherrschen zu können
und dieses Motto wird jetzt hier
problematisiert weil der Macht Aspekt
auch Folgen haben kann die
gesellschaftlich problematisch sind hier
wird auf bürgerliche Gesellschaft
Wirtschaft eingegangen auf Kapitalismus
aber auch auf Faschismus man muss
natürlich diese Schrift vor dem
Hintergrund des Zweiten Weltkriegs
betrachten
weiter geht es in diesem Schriften
Technik ist das Wesen dieses Wissens das
macht es es zielt nicht auf Begriffe auf
Bilder nicht auf das Glück der Einsicht
sondern auf Methode Ausnutzung der
Arbeit andere das Kapital hier steckt
natürlich auch hier steht natürlich auch
Hegel und Marx in der Folge im
Hintergrund hier wird dieses Wissen der
Wissensbegriff der Aufklärung als
abstrakt kritisiert nicht Begriffe
Bilder sondern etwas Entfremdung findet
hier statt Methode Ausnutzung der Arbeit
also der Wissensbegriff der Aufklärung
ist kompatibel mit dem kapitalistischen
System das auf der Ausbeutung der
arbeitenden beruht berücksichtlos gegen
sich selbst hat die Aufklärung noch den
letzten Rest ihres eigenen
Selbstbewusstseins ausgebrannt nur
solches Denken ist hart genug die Mythen
unterbrechen dass ich selbst Gewalt
antun also hier wird jetzt aufbilden
sofern sie im Kampf sich versteht gegen
die Unmündigkeit gegen Aberglauben
problematisch weil sie es mit Gewalt zu
tun hat dieser gewaltaspekt des
kampfcharakters der Aufklärung wird hier
zum ersten Mal wirklich treffend
herausgearbeitet ihre problematischen
Dimension
die Aufklärung im Sinne der
neuzeitlichen Wissenschaft nach Bacon
ersetzt den Begriff durch die Formel
Ursache durch Regel und
Wahrscheinlichkeit also hier sieht man
schon eine Entfremdung von dem direkten
Wirklichkeitsbezug ein weiteres Zitat
was sehr zentral ist ist dass die
moderne Aufklärung das Maß von
Berechenbarkeit und Nützlichkeit als
normatives Kriterium
entwickelt entdeckt und dadurch zu einer
Form von Unterdrückung und dem Prinzip
gleich drittes gleich machens der
Vergleichbarkeit führt alles soll diesem
Ideal unterliegen Aufklärung ist
deswegen totalitär ein weiterer Grund
ist der das Aufklärung nur dasjenige
akzeptiert was ihrem Ideal der
systematizität entspricht
als sein und geschehen wird von der auf
den nur anerkannt was durch Einheit sich
erfassen lässt also hier steckt
natürlich auch ein Ausschlusskriterium
mit im Spiel damit hängt auch zusammen
dass die Aufklärung so jedenfalls
horkanadorno die formale Logik zum
normativen ideal erheben es geht um die
Vereinheitlichung und die
Berechenbarkeit der Welt und ein Schema
das ist natürlich wieder die Abstraktion
die Entfremdung das nicht konkrete die
Zahl wurde zum Kanon der Aufklärung
dieselben Gleichungen beherrschen die
bürgerliche Gerechtigkeit und den
Warenaustausch also man sieht das
moderne aufklärungsideal gibt der
bürgerlichen Gesellschaft ihre
Entfremdung und dem Kapitalismus
Vorschub das ist die problematische
Dimension dieser Auffassung von
Aufklärung
[Musik]
hier herrscht auch sozusagen die Autoren
das Ideal des Äquivalenz sie die
Aufklärung macht
ungleichnamiges komparabel vergleichbar
indem sie es auf abstrakte Größen
reduziert die Aufklärung wird zum Schein
was in Zahlen zuletzt in der 1 nicht
aufgeht die 1 ist natürlich das uniforme
System die Einheit die sich
dasjenige vom Leib behält was nicht in
ihr Schema in Ihr System passt Stichwort
Systemzwang und auch deswegen ist der
Untertitel dieser Schrift philosophische
Fragmente das heißt die Dialekte
Aufklärung als Schrift versteht sich
gerade nicht als ein philosophisches
System sondern als ein Fragment was sich
dem System Zwang auch performativ
entzieht damit knüpfen natürlich die
Autoren an Hegels Kritik des Systems an
wie es in seinen Aphorismus sehr häufig
geäußert hat
die Mythen das ist auch sein
Gegenbegriff zu Aufklärung die waren ihr
eigenes Produkt also auch hier kommt die
Dialektik jetzt gut zum Vorschein die
schon Hegel in seiner Oppositionellen
Struktur von Aufklärung und Unmündigkeit
Aberglaube bemerkt hatte die Mythen sind
in sich schon aufklärerisch verfasst
indem sie darstellen festhalten erklären
die Konfrontation von Aufklärung und
Mythos ist nicht einfach nur
oppositionell zu verstehen sondern ist
dialektisch eine Abhängigkeit zu
verstehen die erst noch aufgeklärt
werden muss der Mythos geht in die
Aufklärung über und die Natur endlose
Objektivität die Menschen bezahlen die
Vermehrung ihrer Macht mit der
Entfremdung von dem worüber sie die
Macht ausüben hierhin liegt auch schon
die Dialektik der Aufklärung begründet
man in fremdet sich von dem worüber man
macht aus man macht sich aber auch auch
gleich davon abhängig
dann haben wir noch ein Zitat dass ich
die Aufklärung mit jedem ihrer Schritte
tiefer in Mythologie verstrickt also
hier sieht man wieder die dialektische
Abhängigkeit sehr gut und auch noch das
Problem der
gegenständlichung im Naturgesetz durch
das diese moderne wissenschaftliche
Auffassung von Aufklärung geprägt ist
dadurch aber durch diese Objektivierung
der Natur desjenigen was nicht in System
passt ist auch Aufklärung mit sozialem
zwangseinheitszwang kompatibel das führt
natürlich auch auf das Problem des
Faschismus in der totalitären Systeme
am Ende bleibt von uns Menschen nichts
körperliches mehr diesen aufklärerischen
modernen Ideal sondern nur noch ein
transzenentalisches logisches Subjekt
der Vernunft die sich der Natur
gegenüber setzt hier steht natürlich
Kant im Hintergrund vielleicht auch die
Karte
das war jetzt ein kurzer Einblick in die
Kritik der Aufklärung bei horkammer
Adorno der nächsten Folge gehen wir auf
ein weiteres Mitglied der Frankfurter
Schule ein auf Jürgen habermaß der eine
Theorie des kommunikativen Handelns
entwickelt hat die wir gemeinsam dann
auch im Seminar als eine Form der
Aufklärung der kommunikativen Aufklärung
interpretieren wollen die sich als eine
Kritik der kommunikativen Unmöglichkeit
versteht vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit bis zur nächsten Folge
auf hast